my name is Elvis Latino I live in
Nairobi that's in Kenya and I'm a
country musician way down and state of
Georgia one two down the road
down there Oh bubbles no emotion the
blood or just in the water
Danny wants to know if I make no dick is
da country music was my first love my
parents I think looking back at it were
very unique in a way because they loved
country music they had all the records
and I listened to all the beautiful
music that was there that kind of like
shaped up the person that was to become
later in my life we identify quite a lot
with country music because of the
message that is in it family love
heartbreak from the coal mines of
Kentucky to the collie phony son I draw
a lot of inspirations from different
singers and different songwriters Garth
Brooks Charley Pride Allen Jackson Don
Williams George Strait ropes and done
the list is endless the struggles they
experience are really Universal every
time I've gone on stage I have to make
sure my audience are with me and they
get my message and usually what I want
them to feel is the role emotions of a
song say this dog with me as a walk the
streets of mumait
I'm just like a vessel but through me
they can feel the emotions and it has to
be real it has to come from your heart
right here by Kazan